welcome everybody let's get right into
it because there's so much to cover uh
one of the most sort of stubborn
specific talking points about so-called
election fraud in general and about the
2020 election
is this idea of dead voters voting now
by dead voters voting it's not literally
people risen from the grave like you
know whatever religious analogy you want
to use the idea is people who have died
have votes counted in their name by a
live person a living person who goes and
says i am this person or that person and
depending on which flavor of this
conspiracy theory you choose
it can be
supposedly a strategy
for those who wish to steal an election
to find
large numbers of names of dead people
still on voter rolls
show up and say i'm that person and to
vote or to do it via absentee ballot
another one of these studies of this has
been done and it turns out that 5 000
supposedly dead georgia voters have been
found alive and well this is a study uh
from the atlantic journal constitution
it's worth reading the entire article
but to give you
the gist of it it says
false claims that there were thousands
of ballots cast in the names of dead
georgia voters can now rest in peace
election investigators found four
absentee ballots four
in the 2020 presidential election from
voters who had died all of them returned
by relatives now that number four can be
looked at in more detail
the state election board referred the
cases to the attorney general's office
the tiny number of ballots cast on
behalf of deceased voters contrasts with
trump's accusation of 5 000 dead voters
in georgia
in the uh it's the latest in a series of
unsubstantiated claims
um
in what so here's an example in one case
a 74 year old widow submitted an
absentee ballot on behalf of her husband
after he died that this is a legit this
is one this is a legitimate case of that
happening
she said he was going to vote republican
i'm going to cancel your ballot by
voting democrat it was a joke between
them
and she got an absentee ballot in her
deceased husband's name
and carried out his wishes she realizes
it was the wrong thing to do and georgia
election officials say there need to be
consequences even for a mistake so they
are presumably going to be prosecuting
that
in another case a ballot was submitted
for deceased augusta voter leon rowe
investigators found that the signature
on his absentee ballot matched the
handwriting of his mother
who died in october of 2020. so they
found four instances now unfortunately
there are people who will see that and
they will say see it does happen and of
course in a country of 331 million as we
always say you can find examples of
everything but to go from that to it
would have changed the results in even
one county never mind in even one state
never mind changing the electoral votes
it's not there and i want to remind
everybody of a really good study
carried out by the bbc
where they looked into this in michigan
and we this is an article from november
of 2020 and they did a really
interesting thing the trumpists were
vaguely saying 10 000 dead people voted
in michigan and they had a list
the bbc picked 30 names at random
and then they added the oldest person on
the list so they had 31 names 11 of them
uh they spoke to the person or a family
member or co-worker and confirmed that
they were actually still alive 11 of the
31 dead voters in michigan were alive
for 17 others there was no public record
of their death and they found clear
evidence that the person was alive
and then they found three people who
were dead and looked into those cases uh
in more detail one of them was like a
senior junior confusion and i believe
two of them were people who
submitted their absentee ballots and
later died so when you hear all of the
story which is there's tons of fraud
dead people voting people voting twice
undocumented immigrants but you wow that
sounds like a lot and then you realize
it's merely a gish gallop and you
examine each of these claims
individually and then with just the dead
voters you go and you look at names and
then you find out they're mostly alive
there's four people in this case
where the allegation is true
sometimes it's junior senior confusion
etc they all fall apart and only when
you break the claim down into its sort
of component parts do you really
understand
that there is nothing there and one
other note on this is
when people actually do the things that
they are accused of doing by the right
they seem to pretty regularly get caught
when it's investigated which is another
sign that generally speaking the
elections are pretty secure
the um
counter side to this
is that when the intelligence community
really issues warnings about things like
foreign interference in elections
the very republicans who will claim they
actually won due to insecure elections
often want to do nothing
about real attempts by foreign powers to
meddle in the elections and uh it
shouldn't surprise us because it's
here's the stated value
which they abandon as soon as the facts
on the ground conflict with what they
want so another study debunking the dead
voter myth
um there is
massive massive blowback now against dr
anthony fauci the director of the nih
because he said yesterday it would be
reasonable
to require proof of vaccination to fly
domestically right now to fly back to
the united states you need a negative
test
to fly and
depending on where you're coming from
vaccination
to go to other countries you often need
vaccination but there is no domestic
airline vaccine requirement right now
it's something that's been talked about
for a while dr fauci without saying he's
recommending it without saying it's
going to happen in fact saying it's
probably not going to happen said well
it wouldn't be an unreasonable thing to
do he appeared on
cnn
yesterday
and was asked about this and he answered
the question let's take a look will you
recommend to president biden there
should be a requirement for vaccination
for domestic travel
you know i i'm not going to tell you
that for the simple reason is that i
don't want to be publicly telling what
i'm recommending to the president
because if then the president doesn't do
it i don't want to make it look he's
going against it the president takes
all recommendations all discussions
and as a group we make a decision about
what's best to do there are pros and
cons to that i mean you've got to ask
yourself
why it is you're making that requirement
if you're making a requirement for
vaccination for people to get on planes
who are coming into the country that's
understandable you don't want to bring
more cases into the country but if
you're talking about requiring
a vaccination to get on a plane
domestically that is just another one of
the requirements that i think is
reasonable to consider and i think
that's what you're talking about when
you heard me make a comment you know
there's requirements that you might want
to get if you want to get into college
or you want to go to a university or you
want to work in certain places when you
make vaccination a requirement that's
another incentive to get more people
vaccinated if you want to do that with
domestic flights i think that's
something that seriously should be
considered so he says it should be
considered and it's reasonable and
people went absolutely crazy about
authoritarian fouchy now in a moment
i'll talk about that requirement
but he even said
after the controversy exploded
it it's not a likely thing to actually
happen so this was later on cnn after
the controversy blew up let's take a
quick look everything when that comes up
as a possibility we put it on the table
and we consider it that does not mean
that it is going to be likely to happen
right now i don't think people should
expect
that we're going to have a requirement
in domestic flights for people to be
vaccinated when i was asked that
question i gave an honest answer it's
it's on the table okay
so
what is
actually logical here in terms of what
might be achieved with such a domestic
airline travel mandate i am actually
ready to say
we are unlikely to vaccinate our way out
of the pandemic at this current point
because
omicron is both so contagious and has a
significant amount of vaccine evasion if
we got to 100 vaccination
maybe but the point of the vaccines
right now is to keep people from getting
very sick omicron it appears
is less severe and what that means we
have to be very specific about what we
mean but it means that as an individual
omicron if you are vaccinated is likely
to cause less serious illness than delta
it seems right now but if you are
unvaccinated you are still quite likely
to get very very sick from omicron so
the point of a vaccine
requirement to get on planes in my mind
would not be to end cases because it
doesn't seem like that's what it would
do but it would be to prevent people
from getting really sick and to prevent
the medical system from getting
overloaded to that point minnesota
emergency physician andrea roland fisher
says the people ending up in the icu are
overwhelmingly unvaccinated second folks
that are
vaccinated and unvaccinated
what's the kind of breakdown from your
estimation of what you've been seeing
i would say the vast majority of people
coming into the icu are those that are
unvaccinated there are a very few
percent of people that are being
admitted to the icu that have been fully
vaccinated
but usually those people are high-risk
people that have critical illness
anyways uh and not
healthy people um that are fully
vaccinated okay so you you hear it there
so the point here is
we would do this because it would get
people vaccinated when we looked at the
polling early in the vaccine mandate
discussion if it was required to go to a
movie theater would that make you go and
get vaccinated nah most people said no
if you got a hundred bucks for getting
vaccinated would that make resistant
people going no most of them wouldn't
but a requirement to present proof of
vaccine to fly domestically something
like 40 of those not yet vaccinated said
that would make me go and get vaccinated
so if the question is would it work it
seems that it would and it seems like it
would also make a very very big impact
there's a very good twitter thread
from dr craig spencer who talks about
all the covet he's been seeing in the er
and what the cases are like on the basis
of vaccination status and he says
the patients with a third booster have
had mild symptoms mostly sore throat a
ton of sore throat fatigue muscle pain
no difficulty breathing no shortness of
breath
the patients with two doses were still
what would be considered mild but they
were more fatigued more fever more
coughing more miserable
still mostly okay
those with one dose of jnj and covid
felt horrible fever for a few days or
more weak tired shortness of breath
cough but still didn't need oxygen and
then for those that had to be admitted
dr craig spencer says almost every
single one was unvaccinated profound
shortness of breath oxygen dropping from
walking needing oxygen to breathe
regularly and so we have to understand
that increasingly
the vaccine is a tool to not get really
sick
and to keep the hospitals
not overloaded
so that if you need to go for a car
accident or for whatever else you're
going to be able to get the care that
you need so are they going to do the
domestic
vaccine requirement
i would bet no at this point in time but
the people flipping out on fauci it's
not up to fauci and fauci is even saying
it's not a likely thing to happen so
as usual much ado about very little
today at 6 p.m we've got the last viewer
and listener town hall of the year hope
you'll join us on the pacman live
youtube channel
through the 31st if you get a full price
yearly membership at joinpacman.com
we will send you a free t-shirt if you
like it
and then also january 1st 2022 we will
be doing a single day membership special
that is going to
blow the walls off of this place if
you'd like to be notified about how to
take advantage of that just get on my
mailing list at
davidpakman.com we're going to take a
quick break what a program we have for
you today quite frankly
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
you've heard me talk before about a sort
of colloquial application of what's
sometimes known as occam's razor and the
way we apply it
colloquially outside of the scientific
world is
simpler explanations all else being
equal are preferable and we should not
come up with unnecessarily complicated
explanations for things that take place
when there are simpler explanations that
are just as good explanations that
require fewer assumptions or fewer uh
unlikely events and that is sort of the
principle front and center in the story
that i want to take a look at with you
guys you might remember that a few
months ago
we jokingly said
you know
when all
of the people that are not vaccinated
or rather put a different way
when so many of the people that get
really sick from covid are unvaccinated
we are going to start to hear from the
right the conspiracy theory
that there is a deliberate effort being
made to infect unvaccinated people to
punish them for not being vaccinated
which is an overly complicated
explanation when we have a simpler
explanation the vaccine protects you
from getting sick right
we have a similar situation here
there was a conspiracy conference and a
bunch of people got coveted
why well because they were together
indoors and kovit's really contagious
and instead of saying oh well we got
coveted from being together and we
spread it
instead they came up with the
explanation that it's actually anthrax
you
it's
how how do you talk sense into someone
who believes this this is a great vice
article explaining it and it reads a
group of unvaccinated people who
attended a huge conspiracy conference in
dallas earlier this month all became
sick in the days after the event with
symptoms like coughing shortness of
breath fever
instead of blaming the coveted global
pandemic the conspiracy theorists think
they were attacked with anthrax
this far-right conspiracy claim began
after a dozen people spent time together
at the reawaken america tour this is
that conference where we've played clips
of alex jones going to it
michael flynn
all sorts of different i think jim
brewer remember when that right-wing
quote comedian jim brewer pretended to
be a bird on stage going voucher
fountain and it was like the most
unfunny clip ever all of that was at
this reawaken america tour and we
started saying a year ago or whenever
they started this thing these are going
to be super spreader events that's
exactly what they became
um
this was a particular
installment of the reawaken america tour
in dallas the weekend of december 10th
the fact that this was likely a covet
outbreak and super spreader event has
been almost entirely ignored
um
james cirowecki
writes on twitter anthrax symptoms
include fever chest pain shortness of
breath cough headache fatigue in other
words many of the symptoms of covid19
but the reawaken america tour features
anti-vaxxers and cove skeptics so it'd
be embarrassing if a bunch of people on
tour caught covet
and there are all of these different um
posts from people talking about this is
actually anthrax
uh let me see if i can get this one
pulled up on the screen
uh i spoke with joe altman earlier today
it appears that he joe von hutton
pulitzer and a dozen other folks that
were present in the green room at the
reawaken america tour are suffering from
symptoms related to an anthrax attack an
anthrax attack so understand the
absurdity of this
they have coveted symptoms
they're all hanging out together indoors
as the wildly contagious omicron variant
spreads and they say well we were
clearly targeted by anthrax now anthrax
is most common in central and south
america agriculturally of course central
and south america
sub-saharan africa
central and southwestern asia southern
and eastern europe the caribbean anthrax
is really rare in the united states so
the explanation that they have
identified for the phenomena of people
having all these covid symptoms is we
were attacked in the green room by
someone who obtained
anthrax
planted it in the green room
and made us all very very sick now
whether
in reality if you believe that there was
an anthrax attack you would report it to
authorities authorities would
investigate these things are taken
really really seriously by law
enforcement and we we've even had a
couple of situations how do i even i
don't even know how i want to say this
we've had situations where
it was important to verify
that there was not anthrax somewhere
and
it's taken very seriously by law
enforcement let's just put it that way
and it's an overly complicated
explanation for
y'all got coveted because covet is
spreading like wildfire it's spreading
like wildfire in dallas that's where the
event was you were all together in an
enclosed room it's occam's razor is it
something really rare to the united
states used as a bio weapon to target
you for your political beliefs or
is it the virus that's everywhere
and once again as is common with
conspiracy theorists going with the
unlikely
far more complicated explanation
i want to do like just one bit of
follow-up on this entire jared schmeck
let's go brandon thing that took place
uh because
even the last bits of the story that
we're still standing are now falling
apart so i
on the one hand who cares about this guy
but the fact that he is being made a
hero
much like kyle rittenhouse is now being
made a hero by the right really tells us
a lot about where the right is now given
who they are lionizing and also
martyring that's another aspect of this
so here's the story
this guy jared schmeck over the holiday
weekend
was able to get on the phone with joe
and jill biden
and during that phone call
he dropped in the phrase let's go
brandon let's go brandon is a euphemism
or a code for f joe biden so he told the
president to go f himself here's a
reminder of that clip this isn't to you
jared this is to the kids that's right
i hope you have a wonderful christmas
yeah i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well
let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree hey by the way
where are you in oregon
where's your home
i think we lost him yeah okay
so
after this took place this guy jared
schmeck started getting criticized
significantly by some although people
like don jr praised him but there were
people criticizing jared schmeck because
it's quite disrespectful if your viewers
respect the office of the president you
don't call up the president and say f
you go f yourself the equivalent of that
and jared schmeck started to
say that he's a victim everybody he was
just expressing his first amendment
rights and people are curtailing those
by criticizing him and it's like no
consequences to your speech
are also protected by the very same free
speech right that we all share
um and he also said something
interesting which is i'm not a trumper
i respect joe biden i'm not a trumper i
just have concerns
cut to yesterday when jared schmeck
appeared with former trump adviser and
breitbart propagandist steve bannon
wearing a red maga hat saying the
election was 100 stolen and he wants us
to believe he's not a trumper he's just
a guy expressing his concerns it's just
a pathetic joke take a look at the video
let's listen to the audio
i know it was said in a in a joking
manner in a humorous manner but it's a
very serious uh thing and i mean it's
it was one way for me to like man i got
a chance right now to to voice my
disapproval of
of this man and his administration
and
what is that what is that what is that
what is that disa you're you're john q
public what is that what is that
disapproval can you define that for us
yeah yeah by the way
the idea that we would particular like
it's great to hear from just random
people that's great we want to know we
want to take the pulse of what's going
on and hear from people
but steve bannon's interest
in hearing from this guy who we only
know about because he told the pres
president to go f himself like who in
particular cares what this guy has to
say let's go brandon is and i've said it
in other articles i am a christian man
uh it's for me it's god first and
foremost i don't follow any one man
blindly um some of the media's run with
that and said i don't support donald
trump that's absolutely false donald
trump and remember he said i'm not a
trumper trump is my president and he
should still be president right now
the election was 100 stolen um so i just
want to make that clear um but uh
let's go brandon is is more than just f
joe biden let's go brandon is
encompasses the the entirety of our
frustration with
joe biden the administration the leftist
mob the cancel culture the mainstream
media they're the ones who made this uh
a thing
and uh where
f joe biden is about
the cancel culture
what is this guy talking about well as
as conservatives we're able to find
humor in this um but there's terrible
things going on uh we've got the debacle
in afghanistan i mean they're not even
talking about it so it's a verbal
inkblot of just
unhinged disjointed talking points but
he's not a trumper oh and also he's
wearing a red maga hat anymore it's
crazy to me how quickly they they forgot
that story and no one's talking about it
there's still people trapped over there
um we've got the
supply chain issues we've got the
inflation rates
we've got uh terrible policies on
abortion i'm a very pro-life person um
and uh absolutely terrible
what's funny about just as like a i mean
this
it's hard to find a more ignorant person
who thinks they are really informed
the abortion line just to pick one thing
right the abortion line is particularly
wacky
because joe biden's been president 11
months almost almost a year right
actually eleven three weeks short of a
year joe biden has been president
there has been no loosening of abortion
policy since joe biden took over from
donald trump and in fact
with the texas abortion law if anything
it is harder today to get an abortion
overall in the united states than it was
11 months ago when joe biden became
president so when you actually look at
what these folks are saying and this
there's lots of people who don't even
pay attention to politics they just i
don't care about politics you ask them
who's the vice president they might not
even know like people who are just
completely tuned out
this guy is an example of someone who
believes they are knowledgeable about
what's going on
and people like this vote
and he has
no idea whatsoever and at the end of the
day he basically told the president of
the united states fu to his face
and now he's calling himself the victim
so let's
let's
make this the final point on the jared
schmeck story
he's no one any of us should care about
uh in terms of his opinion and he
despite being a christian
and being from the side that says we've
got to have the right you know tone and
respect for all of these different
institutions
he is now being criticized because he
told the president to go f himself
that's that's the end of the story and
we'll have these clips on our instagram
if you are listening today and want to
watch them find us there uh david pakman
show on instagram
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show it's great to welcome to the
program today stephen danziger who's a
human rights attorney who helped
indigenous groups in ecuador win a
historic 10 billion dollar pollution
judgment against chevron if you want to
help what he's doing you can go to
freedonziger.com
it's really great having you on i
appreciate your time
well thanks for having me david i
appreciate it so to start with
what first brought your attention to the
effects of oil drilling
uh in ecuador and and and how did you
first get involved in all of this
yeah that's a great question i mean i
was a year out of law school back in the
early 90s
i was
one of my classmates was from ecuador
and he told me about this and i was part
of a team in the early 90s that went
down to investigate what turned out to
be you know the worst oil disaster on
the planet or so we thought we called it
the amazon chernobyl
essentially what we discovered is that
texaco an american company now chevron
had deliberately dumped billions of
gallons of cancer-causing oil waste onto
indigenous ancestral lands in the amazon
creating a wave of cancers and other
health and economic problems for the
people
we filed a lawsuit
as a result of that first trip and 28
years later here i am still our team is
still fighting to hold chevron
accountable we won the lawsuit by the
way they just have not paid yet
um and that's where the battle is at
this point
there are so many different aspects of
this to talk about including the
eventual charges against you as you talk
about the fact that the judgment has has
not been paid just to pick something and
and we'll kind of go through these
different things
as this was going on and you were
working on this the documentary film
crude was being produced
and one might argue that the production
of the film
opened the door
to allege fraud against you by what was
allegedly left out of the film so can
you talk to us a little bit about your
involvement in the film and whether in
hindsight it was a mistake
sure um so in 2007 joe burlinger who's
an acclaimed documentary filmmaker
decided to make a film about you know
really this epic battle by indigenous
groups against chevron
and their legal team of which i was a
part
um i thought the film was great it came
out in 2009 it's called crude you can
still get it on netflix or on youtube
but more to the point is chevron when
they started to lose the case in ecuador
based on the evidence tried to exploit
the film to come after me
let me be very very clear chevron has
alleged that i committed some sort of
fraud down in ecuador i reject that it's
never been proven i've never been
charged with a crime and the reality is
28 different appellate judges six
appellate courts in ecuador and canada
have rejected that that theory
but they tried to claim that based on
the movie
and some certain things i said in the
movie which frankly were in politic you
know just
stuff i was saying with the camera on
you know 15 years ago was somehow
evidence of fraud and it's never been
accepted by any court
and i reject it and again you know the
judgment in ecuador that i help win
um has been affirmed by multiple
appellate courts around the world so
it's a valid judgment and you know i
just reject that but it's a good film
people want to see it because it really
does capture a lot of what was going on
in ecuador at the time it's so to and to
answer the one piece of that that i that
i didn't hear an answer to in hindsight
did it create problems for that film to
be well that's that's a question you
know it's funny that's a very that's an
important question
and i get asked that a fair amount like
if you could do it over would you have
made the film yeah um i don't know you
know when you go through a journey like
i've been on you sort of operate on the
information you have at the time you
make decisions and the information i had
at the time and and my clients more
importantly the people of ecuador i was
working with thought it would be really
good for their campaign to illuminate
via a film
you know the injustices that were being
inflicted upon them by chevron
um you know i nor did they anticipate
that how chevron would try to exploit it
for litigation purposes had we known
that maybe my clients would have made a
different decision but you know at this
point there's water under the bridge the
fact is the film is out there yeah it's
a good film and i think overall my
personal assessment is that it helps the
campaign
so okay i want to be precise in how i
kind of broach this this next topic as
you pointed out
there have been
allegations made that the judgment you
obtained
was obtained
through
uh
racketeering extortion wire fraud
witness tampering money laundering etc
you've denied those allegations and you
correctly point out
those have not been proven in court it's
beyond my ability here to examine every
single one of those individually i've
done a fair share of research about this
i can't unequivocally say there's no
merit to any of it but you're completely
right that none of it's been proven in
court ultimately your imprisonment in
the united states and the suspension of
your law license was not based on any of
that
but contempt is that correct that's
contempt of court yes and that is a
misdemeanor
it was treated that way in my case i
mean if i may i think there's a bigger
issue here that i'd like to point out
fairly limited time we have yeah you
know because there's obviously no way in
this limited time we go through all
these allegations right
you know the big issue is it's been
proven in a court of law and chevron has
admitted that its predecessor company
texaco deliberately dumped literally
billions of gallons of toxic waste in
the amazon which is
literally killing thousands of people as
we speak yes
in my view as their defense strategy
they're like oh let's distract from that
by focusing on steve donziger okay so
the more we talk about me and i sort of
you know when i agree to be on the show
like i obviously knew this but like the
more we talk about me the less we talk
about the real problem
which is the poisoning of the amazon in
a way that is decimating indigenous
groups even hurtling them toward
extinction that's the real issue here so
the issue's not me it's them now if we
want to talk about me and their
allegations against me i'm happy to do
that and i do that all the time because
again they've never been proven in a
court of law and i you know puts me on
the defensive which i don't like yeah
and to be clear about them but yeah but
they're simply i'm just telling you
they're simply unproven
and in my view they're not true it's
just a strategy it's like a corporate
playbook to distract attention from a
human rights atrocity that chevron
committed by focusing on the lawyer and
you see this all the time and the bigger
issue to me in in a society where and i
don't think this is a right left
political issue it's like what kind of
society do we want to have where you can
advocate for people you know lawyers
should be able to do their jobs and
advocate without being personally
attacked by the party that they beat in
court and that's what's happened to me
with the help unfortunately of a federal
judge here
who i've accused of being you know
biased and and the final thing i'll
point out
the united nations working group on
arbitrary detention which is a very
respected legal body that's been cited
by our own state department on many of
an occasion where they point out people
who've been arbitrarily detained
ruled in september that the united
states government should release me
immediately i'm just not free even
though i'm home i'm i'm in detention at
home right now yes they should release
me immediately and paying me
compensation because my detention
violates multiple provisions of
international law and is clearly
retaliation against my advocacy for
indigenous groups in a case that has
been i think manipulated by chevron and
the fossil fuel industry i know that's a
lot to absorb
but the larger issue is my case raises
it goes way beyond me and it really
raises a lot of issues about what kind
of freedom we want what what's the role
of lawyers in our society can you do
climate justice work without being
locked up i mean what's happened to me i
think is just wrong and it's not
indicative of the best part of our
country it's very unusual in the united
states to have a lawyer a climate
justice lawyer like me locked up and i
just think it's it's wrong
with no question and to be clear if i
don't mention as a jumping off point for
this conversation that the allegations
exist i'm not doing my job but i can't
completely concede it's beyond the scope
of this to adjudicate that i'm totally
cool with how you're asking the question
and i love your work generally i'm happy
to take the question i just wanted to
make the larger point
when it comes to
the ulterior motives
what is your assertion about the role of
the american
court system
judge kaplan etc and
chevron formerly known as texaco
look i think as a general matter our
federal judiciary in particular has
become very politicized in the last two
three decades
in a way it never was before and i think
i'm sort of paying the price for that
personally right now um you know there's
a whole there's different groups in the
judiciary and i think it's the
appointment of judges has become so
political
that you're getting judges now on the
bench that are really carrying out i
think
political agendas rather than doing what
they should be doing which is looking at
the facts and ruling on the law in the
most neutral way possible so
you know what judge kaplan has done to
engineer my detention without a jury i
want to emphasize that i never had a
jury
he manipulated the case such that you
know that i wouldn't get a jury
i couldn't defend myself you know in
other words the allegation against me on
the contempt side was that i didn't
comply with his court order that i
turned my computer over to chevron and i
the reason i didn't comply is i appealed
it
to protect the privileges held by my
clients in ecuador their privileged
information their identities they would
have been hurt had this information been
released and been put at risk their
lives would have been put at risk
so i thought i behaved ethically and
i'll point out there's never been a
lawyer in the history of our country
who's been charged criminally for doing
what i did that is challenging a civil
discovery order on appeal it's never
happened before so why is it happening
to the one guy who actually won a 10
billion dollar judgment against chevron
i mean it makes no sense and i'll make
this point when judge kaplan charged me
he went to the sdny the federal
prosecutor here in manhattan
to ask them to prosecute the case and
they refused to prosecute me he then
rather than letting it sit he then
appointed a private law firm to
prosecute me seward and kissel and he
didn't disclose and we found out seven
months later that this law firm seward
and kissel had had chevron as a client
it has massive has numerous clients at
high levels of the fossil fuel industry
so this became in my opinion the
nation's first private criminal
prosecution
they immediately detained me pre-trial
on a misdemeanor which is unheard of i
mean it locked me up in my home with an
ankle bracelet and because it covered
the trial kept getting delayed that
ended up lasting 20 um four months i'm
sorry 26 months two years and two months
and on top of that the judge who was
also appointed by judge kaplan judge
prescott
sentenced me to six months in prison
where i ended up reporting to federal
prison for
you know defending my clients in the
amazon and i just think it was grossly
unfair i ended up getting out after 45
days but i'm now back home in detention
to serve the rest of my sentence so all
in all for this misdemeanor where the
maximum sentence
is six months i am going to end up
serving close to three years by the time
it's over and so a couple of other
details on that the at one point there
was an 800 000
bail set for a misdemeanor that's the
highest in u.s history for a misdemeanor
if i understand correctly
that's our understanding so on top of
being the first person charged with this
kind of misdemeanor locked up prior to
trial
i was also given the highest bail ever
for a lawyer on a misdemeanor in u.s
history and i'll point out that that 800
000 bail was actually higher than three
of the four
police officers involved in the killing
of george floyd which i find astounding
i mean
there's people who commit serious
serious violent crimes who have lower
bails than i got
um when judge prescott uh
wrote the ruling against you
there was this question
as to
what connect specific connection there
was with the ruling
in ecuador and i know you've generally
spoken about
political interests
you know among the ranks of judges etc
is there anything more specific about
judge prescott that you think should be
understood or known about
the connection to fossil fuels
yes i mean and let me just say i i
respect judges in the rule of law like
i'm i'm i'm a lawyer um and i don't mean
to disrespect judge prescott but there's
a couple of problems with her presiding
over my case one is she's a leader of
the federalist society which of to which
chevron is probably the largest funder
the federalist society is a legal
organization it's a fine legal
organization but it is very
pro-corporate and a lot of corporations
fund it and she is a very public leader
and she you know identifies with an
organization that gets funds from
chevron
and i just think that's a major conflict
of interest i don't think she should
have presided over my case
and
you know the other thing i'll point out
about judge prescott is i don't think
she ever should have been appointed to
this case because you know there's rules
here in the federal judiciary and in new
york in particular that cases need to be
signed randomly
and judge kaplan i believe chose her for
a reason they're close colleagues
they've been on the bench together for
over 25 years
and i think she treated me very unfairly
i mean she's the one who made the
decision to lock me up pre-trial for
over two years
you know on a theory that i was a risk
of flight like i'm really gonna i have a
wife and a teenage son i'm really gonna
flee it's absurd the country
um you know to avoid a misdemeanor i
mean so so there was all these things
happening where i believe she and judge
kaplan sort of
colluded to impose a very punitive
um
suffering on me punishment before i was
ever convicted
of a crime and i will point out that my
so-called conviction which again i
assert my innocence it's under appeal
okay right now
um was imposed without a jury i insisted
on a jury
you know so i could have an unbiased
fact finder rather than a person i
believe was a biased judge and judge
prescott repeatedly denied me a jury
repeatedly refused to remove the
prosecutor even though she was from the
chevron law firm the private prosecutor
so there are all these features to the
trial that led the united nations jurors
to conclude there was what they called a
staggering level of judicial bias in my
case
it's uh it's an incredible and
disturbing story in a number of
different ways we've been speaking with
stephen dunziger and you can learn much
more about what's going on at
freedonziger.com
i really appreciate your time and uh you
giving us your insights into what took
place thank you david i appreciate your
work as well thanks for having me
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pacman
join the reddit community at
davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy
as many of you know there's this cadre
of particularly extreme republican
members of congress right now often we
talk about marjorie taylor greene lauren
bobert madison cothorn is three of the
sort of newer
radical republicans now i could not care
less about madison cawthorne's personal
life it turns out that madison cawthorne
is getting divorced from his wife after
a year of marriage i could not care less
i just don't care and i wouldn't even be
talking about it except for the fact
that in the context of this divorce a
very very strange video has come up
in which madison cothorn
explains the story
of how
he met his wife
and it involves attending a crossfit
competition that didn't really exist
after visiting russia and meeting
someone and it all just stinks to high
heaven
of russian compramot or some kind of
honeypot intelligence operation now i
want to be clear i'm not saying that's
what it is
it's just incredible that kawthorne
himself seems to have no self-awareness
whatsoever
that the story of how they met is just a
little bit weird yahoo news has an
article about it
where
they write a video has resurfaced of
madison cawthorne saying he met his
soon-to-be ex-wife at a fake crossfit
competition organized by a u.s army
captain that he met in russia
um
the tale involves a casino in st
petersburg russia that led to a fake
crossfit competition in miami which
kawthorne referred to as a sham to
introduce him to the woman who would
become his fiancee now this is an 18
month old video it's resurfaced i had
never seen this before
and he talks about going to russia on a
vacation
the story is all very very strange so
let's look at the video and this already
with nearly 3 million views because it's
just
so bizarre
and so we took the risk to do that
surgery and so when i decided to do that
i said well doctor let me go on one last
trip just in case i'm not going to be
able to ever get on an airplane again
and then uh so he said okay we'll do
well you'll be in a lot of pain i said
that's it's it's worth it so me and a
bunch of my friends we went to uh we we
got to go over to um the
over to we're very close to russia so
even here it's a little weird
because he he it sounds like he's going
to say something else and then he says
very close to russia let me just go back
there okay we got to go over to um the
over to we're very close to russia we
got went to sweden and norway and we had
just an incredible vacation it was great
i was in a lot of pain the whole time
but it was wonderful so he says they
went to sweden and norway uh but then we
got on a boat and went into uh st
petersburg in russia okay
now
i'm already suspicious of this story
because what he's saying could be true
he says they went to sweden and norway
and got on a boat to russia
most people who do the ferry to st
petersburg
go from helsinki finland look at a map
and you'll see geographically
norway to russia
makes no sense on i think you can get a
boat i think it's multiple days
sweden to st petersburg there is a ferry
i think it's close to 40 hours and
could make did they could they have
taken a 35-40 hour ferry
maybe not that many people do it
typically people go helsinki to st
petersburg and you see that it's much
closer so his hesitation combined with
saying
then we got on a boat
it already is sort of weird but that's
nothing compared to where it's gonna go
and you know we just decided to take a
hundred dollars each and go into a
casino and see how it went
and you know i
ended up meeting uh an american there
who was a captain in the army and he was
originally from miami and so we hit it
off created a really great relationship
and stayed in contact for about a year
and a half
until later i was down to miami for work
and uh he he texted me and said hey
would you like to come compete in a
crossfit competition and so i was i got
a little laugh and said well well todd
i'm in a wheelchair i obviously can't do
crossfit and he said well just do the
pull-up section i was like okay that
sounds good and so i show up but anyways
it all was a sham it was a fake crossfit
competition he just wanted me to put me
in the same room with the uh the girl
who was eventually going to become my
fiancee and so we did her and i hit it
off and it was it was a really it's been
a magical relationship ever since now
if that doesn't seem extremely bizarre
to anybody else then i
he
does any of the story make sense to
anybody
he was
in sweden and norway and took a boat to
st petersburg which is already something
very few people do
at a casino he happens to meet a us army
captain
who
stays in touch with him at a russian
casino
invites him to a crossfit competition
why that guy would think hey you know
what
i can't just tell him i've got someone i
want you to meet down here
he has to create a sham
the belief of a sham crossfit
competition to get him down there to
meet a woman
why did this woman want to meet him what
did the woman know about him and what
none of the story makes sense now again
we don't know anything but it is a wacky
and bizarre story and maybe at some
point we'll learn more about what the
backstory here is but needless to say
that relationship is ending okay this
you have to see
donald trump is really in trouble with
his own followers donald trump has made
two pro-vaccine public comments over the
last week or ten days
and he is in so much trouble with his
own followers that he had to go to
marjory taylor green to try to clean it
up let me remind you of what took place
first of all at the trump bill o'reilly
event from last i believe it was early
last week or late the previous week
donald trump saying the vaccine's good
and i got the booster and the crowd
booing take a look
but look we did something that was
historic
we saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide we together all of us not me
we
we got a vaccine done three vaccines
done and tremendous therapeutics like
regeneron and other things that have
saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine
millions and millions of people i think
this would have been the spanish flu of
1917 where up to a hundred million
people died this was going to ravage the
country far beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives take credit
don't let them take that away from you
okay so the president made do you agree
with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't no none
that's a very tiny group of so that was
the first incident second incident was
donald trump interviewed by candace
owens candace owens wanting to do the
anti-vaxx stuff with trump and trump
saying no the vaccines are good the
vaccines are an accomplishment and the
people that are getting sick and dying
are the people who are unvaccinated
remember that clip we see the corruption
right it doesn't seem like anybody ever
pays for the corruption and right now
we're seeing corruption live even in
terms of big pharma which is a huge
topic on the minds of mothers especially
you're seeing what's happening at these
school board meetings where do you stand
on these vaccine mayonnaise and
obviously i know that you are you are
pro vaccine obviously you did everything
you could to get this vaccine out i know
it was one of the greatest achievements
we did in less than nine months to be
able to do that but where but now it's
taken a twist right it's gotten now we
went from this is a good thing and
people should have this option to
military men you're going to have to
resign because you're not getting this
vaccine where do you stand on that well
i stand on forget about the mandates
that people have to have their freedom
but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917
remember the spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were a lot of people don't know that the
soldiers got so sick it was a terrible
thing there was no vaccines it would
know anything i came up with a vaccine
with three vaccines all are very very
good came up with three of them in less
than nine months it was supposed to take
five to twelve years
and yeah people have died under cobit
this year by the way under joe biden
then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how the vaccine work but
some people aren't taking the ones the
ones that get very sick and go to the
hospital are the ones that don't take
the vaccine but it's still their choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form people aren't
dying when they take the vaccine
of children this has thrown the trump
world into a tailspin we talked about it
yesterday so many trump followers
believe that they have been
um uh backstabbed for lack of a better
term by donald trump and so donald trump
now trying to clean it up through
marjorie taylor greene and marjorie
taylor green is sort of the perfect
person to do it as an anti-vaxx
republican she put together this big
twitter thread where she says i just got
off the phone with trump
we talked about vaccines and mandates we
talked about covid and how the virus
from china has been politicized she says
i have president trump's permission to
tell you all he is 100
against the mandates
but he encourages everyone to get the
vaccine he also said if he was president
he would never mandate vaccines and no
one would be fired the key thing to
remember is where covet came from
china
we should be holding those who made the
virus accountable
made the virus made the virus a very
dubious term given what we know about it
and protecting our freedoms while
promoting life-saving treatments and
giving the vaccines to those who want it
not forced
not forced
for everyone that criticizes trump about
when kovitz started with shoulda coulda
woulda's i think he administration did
the best they could
the virus was brand new we'd never seen
anything like it biden deserves the
criticism and then they just move on to
other apologia trump says you wouldn't
be paying these gas prices if he was in
charge keystone would be under for under
construction biden is a disgrace
on and on going on to talk about iran
and other things um this is actual
sort of crisis management done in a
really really strange way trump said
something for once that's true
and for once that's uncontroversial the
people disproportionately dying from
covet are the people without a vaccine
even in the context of omicron as we
talked about earlier and trump's
audience is so weaponized against him
that they went nuts
and now he's going to marjorie taylor
green to try to help him clean it up
let's hope
that this is trump's undoing trump
finally telling the truth about
something maybe his undoing with his own
followers the monster he created
is completely out of control
and has turned against him and it is
delightful to see
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a really important topic via
voicemail
the youtube recommendation algorithm
take a listen to this
hey david a longtime listener um just
had a quick question for you uh kind of
a philosophical question uh with the
youtube ad algorithm it's incredibly
easy for you know big right-wing
audience or right-wing um groups uh to
buy up ad space and uh blast across and
take over political channels so for
example if i watch you know go to watch
a clip of your show i have to go through
a barrier of right-wing advertisements
if i go and watch certain um you know
atheist channels for example i have to
go through religious ads before i can
get to the content yeah so there's two
different things going on here there's
two things going on here number one
despite claims of left-wing bias on all
of these platforms
um
facebook and also youtube regularly
recommend extreme right wing and
conspiracy content even to people who
only are deliberately consuming
left-wing stuff i hear it all the time
from my audience that's number one but
number two
the right buys ads on youtube in a way
that the left doesn't and i've talked
about this before and the right does
this in a lot of different areas they
are willing to sort of
have these lost leaders where they say
even if we don't make money
by spending money in this way we're
going to do it to bring people in put
people's attention in front of our
right-wing content and so even when you
watch left-wing content you often get
ads for right-wing publishers why
because the right-wing publishers are
disproportionately buying pre-roll ads
on youtube and this is part of why they
often are doing so well in terms of
ground game because they're willing to
train up college grads right we talk
about the think tanks and the other
organizations that they're willing to
lose money
training people and getting people into
their orbit and youtube ad spend is just
another example of that i don't know
what we can do to change it i don't know
we have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about the new cdc guidelines
for quarantine and isolation under
omicron we will talk about a judge
reconsidering a 110 year sentence for a
big uh
truck accident that killed four people
and we will also talk about
a controversial decision by tesla all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com
and get instant access we'll see you
then